[Música]
en esta marcha Parisina optaron por
manifestarse al son de la música hubo
37.000 personas en la capital según la
prefectura de la policía una cifra
inferior a las 93.000 anunciadas hace
cinco días una movilización menor en
París que el sábado pasado pero un
mensaje que no cambia no al proyecto de
reforma de las pensiones y creo que la
reforma que Proponen es in
justa en relación con las mujeres en
relación con las personas que tienen
carreras largas en relación con las
personas que tienen trabajos difíciles a
nivel físico e incluso psicológico
actualmente hay una presión enorme en
las empresas en el oeste también eran
menos numerosos que el sábado entre
6.700 y 12.000 un descenso que según la
cgt se explica por el inicio de las
vacaciones escolares en la región los
manifestantes no dejaron de hacer gala
de imaginación en sus pancartas a pesar
del humor la reivindicaciones son serias
todos estamos en contra de que se rebaje
la edad de jubilación a los 64 años es
una lucha con todos los sindicatos Así
que hoy estamos juntos y es una fuerza
para nosotros poder afirmarnos juntos
como intersindicato más al sur los
representantes sindicales eligieron la
ciudad de alvi en el tag para protestar
querían convertirla en el epicentro
provincial de la protesta
La idea es mantener la movilización y
que cada día lo sábado venga gente nueva
Así que es un movimiento que está bien
anclado un movimiento de fondo y hoy es
un nuevo día de movilización iba a decir
que las cifras no importan Hoy
hay gente en huelga y has notado Que no
se ha acabado porque quedan reuniones
por venir
la próxima cita será el 7 de marzo fecha
en la que Jean Luke de la Francia
insumisa Llama a bloquearlo todo